the United States will withdraw from the
Paris climate Accord I was elected to
represent the citizens of Pittsburgh not
Paris Pittsburgh now what was upsetting
about that and that alliteration was a
stereotype of our past but Pittsburgh is
poised and ready to lead in the 21st
century we're seeing cities and states
and companies and individuals saying we
are still in even with the president
pulling us out of one of the most
important treaties when every other
major country in the world has said we
are going to come together and commit to
dealing with climate change I continue
to be shocked at how close the water has
been approaching just on the beach sea
level rise is completely apparent in
Miami we had six and a half foot of
water on the main level of the house for
over a week stuff that was in our
bedroom wound up in the garage and stuff
that was in the garage
I imagine that way down in Louisiana now
the storms are becoming stronger in
Puerto Rico the worst thing is to think
that that reality will repeat not a lot
survived a fire in Ventura County it
burns so hot that everything just
liquefied and not be able to save
anything it was just really hard if
we're going to avoid reaching
catastrophic levels of warming we need
to be putting our foot on the renewable
energy acceleration pedal
the transformation towards a renewable
energy future is the greatest economic
opportunity of the 21st century
businesses have lined up to say we're
still committing to the Paris Accord
because it's good for their bottom line
my daughter Fayed she made the decision
that when was where she wanted to be
this is an opportunity hasn't been
available in America for a long long
time the solar industry is offering that
second-chance opportunities individuals
like myself there's a matter of your
Republican Democrat independent you have
a role to play here and if we look at it
as an American Marshall Plan we can
exceed the goals of the Paris agreement
taking control of our future we have the
right to a future we have the right to
these basic necessities that we need to
live
and we the people need to take action
our lives are at stake here